no surfing film will ever be Point Break
it's impossible Point Break man Point
Break chasing maverick stars Gerard
Butler he's this guy who's a surfer in
the Maverick is apparently like this
myth this giant surf wave that's huge
that no one believes in but he knows
they exist him and three other guys when
they know it's coming to this Beach they
go and they ride it and the movie starts
out with a little kid he loves surfing
he's very intrigued by surfing and it
goes seven years later and everything
and now he's an adult and he wants
Gerard Butler to teach him how to surf
these Mavericks because it's his dream
he wants to surf these things the true
story about a surfer named Jay Moriarty
now I'm pretty sure that the majority of
this film is fictionalized unless this
man led the most cliched life of all
time not a good movie just gonna say
that it right up front I'm disappointed
because it's co-directed by Curtis
Hanson the man who made LA Confidential
Wonder Boys in her shoes and then he
made lucky you with Eric Bana which
wasn't very good and now he's made this
which was even worse it's kind of like a
father-son tale you know cuz Gerard
Butler is like the father figure and
this kid he is the son you know he
doesn't really have a dad around
elisabeth shue is his mom it's just
there is so much melodramatic cheesy
soap opera stuff around these characters
that it just it doesn't work there's
some really great surfing imagery for
sure and Butler is actually really good
in this movie I thought he was by far
the best part of this film I liked his
character I thought that he gave a lot
of heart to the movie but I got to say
this kid oh my god
the Maine kid in this movie it's his
first movie ever
he is awful like I feel bad saying this
because I don't like to say this about
people like it's his first movie okay I
feel bad saying this but it he was bad
in this movie he gave a very wooden
performance it was just so blank and
fake and just it was bad was one of the
worst performances I've seen all year
I'm sorry it was terrible you can feel
like the movie is trying to go places
like there's a heart there you know like
it has good intentions but there's like
after
school special twists and turns I'm not
gonna say you because I don't want to
spoil it but somewhere in this movie
just flat-out keels over and dies for no
reason
there was like no point to that at all
it just happened and now the characters
are sad and they can have scenes where
they comfort each other and stuff and it
just it didn't work the movie was just
really poorly written very chizel II
acted except for Gerard Butler I was
disappointed because the the filmmakers
behind this movie could have made a
better movie and it just did this story
wasn't as interesting as it could have
been very predictable movie it just
didn't feel right there's just there
wasn't any meat there it was missing
realism that's it it was missing realism
it just felt very fake I'm gonna give
chasing Mavericks a c-minus thanks
always for watching guys and if you
liked this review then you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes